[Musique]
la zone dans laquelle nous avions placé
c'est ce projet en plein parc des
virunga où les jeunes peuvent être
tentés d intégrer ou d'être manipulés
avec le multiples groupes armés qui a
déjà compté ici dans dans le parc et
nous nous pensons que cette occupation
est lady moins positive pour éviter à
ses gènes décès sentir manipulés ou
utiliser
[Musique]
quand on parle de l'est de la rdc la
plupart ne voyais qu'ils groupe germain
ne voit que les gènes qui sont dans les
groupes armés et pour nous on a voulu on
n'a pas voulu que ces histoires
continuent alors nous avons jugé les
pannes ces jeunes et les sensibiliser à
fait qu'ils comprennent qu'ils aient le
parc national de virunga c'est moyen de
développement pourrait manquer les
manceaux prennent des coups les uns ni
quoique and animals qui me navre
d'haqqani cool que vous teniez com mais
la chérit
sa vie n'est ni que ces cas bombe ou un
mini fois guy nzouba que la christiane
on a un bel band fille car pour le connu
à lille wasquehal nous valions diack à
sa guise et un message à zenata offshore
placement pas les vôtres
[Musique]